[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
édition du grand jt des territoires sur
tv5monde et sur vos chaînes locales de
la tnt
voici tout de suite les titres de
l'actualité avec à la une les résultats
du baccalauréat ils sont tombés cette
semaine plus de 90 % de réussite pour
une édition marquée par l'aco vide 19 et
une nouvelle formule pour l'épreuve mais
vous le verrez la joie elle reste la
même
quand les résultats sont positifs sujet
à suivre dès le début de cette édition
avec vosges télévision un nouveau congé
de paternité également dans l'actualité
il est désormais de 28 jours une bonne
nouvelle pour toute la famille et
notamment les principaux concernés les
papas comme l'a constaté la rédaction de
tl7 dans la loire après orléans place à
reims dont yann moix
l'auteur vient de publier aux éditions
grasset son dernier ouvrage dans lequel
il revient sur ses 20 ans des années pas
toujours heureuses vous l'entendrez dans
ce journal
et puis nous prendrons l'air en fin de
jt à metz les frigos c'est un lieu
festif et culturel ont ouvert nous
accueillerons de nombreuses animations
tout l'été pour le plus grand bonheur
des habitants reportage de giat n'osait
rêver enfin d'édition on débute ce
journal avec les résultats du
baccalauréat l'édition 2021 a été marqué
du sceau de la crise sanitaire avec le
contrôle continu renforcée et la
naissance du grand oral voulue par le
ministre de l'éducation jean michel
blanquer
ces nouveautés n'ont pas empêché les
cris de joie habituel de s'exprimer au
moment de la découverte des résultats
dans les vosges anthony sap et thierry
lasson pour vosges télévision ont
assisté à ce bon moment pour certains
c'est évidemment l'image du jour l'heure
du verdict et du soulagement pour les
candidats au bac 2021 une session
marquée par la crise sanitaire mais
aussi par la réforme blanc caire la
prise en compte du contrôle continu et
la naissance du grand oral
mais petit retour en arrière nous sommes
dans la cour du lycée l'a piqué epinal
quelques minutes seulement avant les
résultats
d'habitude ils sont nombreux à cette
heure-là attendre que les volets se lève
et dévoile les feuilles d'admission se
mardi matin peu avant 10 heures ils
n'étaient qu'une poignée dont chloé
manon et axel impatiente de voir se
terminer une année scolaire pas tout à
fait comme les autres
c'était beaucoup plus stressant parce
qu'on a été confiné un mois et qu'on
n'avait pas pour tous les journaux mais
pour un jour sur deux ici le stress
toute l'année d'avoir des bonnes notes
pour avoir une bonne moyenne avec le
contrôle continu
ça a été stressant tout au long de
l'année et encore plus au moment du
grand oral puisqu'on n'a pas été autant
préparé c'était une nouvelle épreuve on
n'avait jamais passé doha l'avant donc
mais ça s'est bien passé on a vécu une
année très compliquée qui s'est
relativement plutôt bien déroulé grâce à
la mise en place de l'enseignement à
distance
on a progressé par rapport à
l'utilisation des outils numériques
chose qui n'était pas gagné il faut le
dire et alors que maintenant je veux
dire c'est plutôt rentrer dans les
usages le suspense en tout cas été
finalement assez réduit ce mardi matin
puisque pour cette première édition du
bac blanc caire le contrôle continu
représenter plus de 80 % de la note
finale
plusieurs examens sur table ayant été
annulée rester le grand oral est
l'épreuve de philo mais pour chloé manon
et axel pas question de parler d'un bac
au rabais
la question que c'est moins important
parce qu'on avait du contrôle continu
mais on a quand même travaillé l'année
pour avoir des bonnes notes
oui c'est un bac quiconque ce qu'on a
travaillé toute l'année donc on a fait
des efforts pour l'avoir donc je pense
que oui après il sera pas vu de la même
façon par tout le monde
nos parents ils pensent pas forcément la
même chose que nous mais c'est comme ça
ce bac en tout cas elles ont bel et bien
décroché elle tenait à découvrir les
résultats sur place ensemble au lycée
plutôt que d'apprendre comme beaucoup la
nouvelle sur le net c'est la tradition
alors on vient
même s'il ya moins de monde que les
autres années oui bah c'est pas grave
moi plus facilement il ne leur reste
donc plus qu'à fêter ça elles
profiteront ensuite de leurs vacances
avec ou sans jobs d'été avant de
poursuivre leurs études dans des iut et
des facultés du département c'est
désormais officiel depuis le 1er juillet
le congé paternité et de 28 jours contre
14 jusqu'à présent la durée double pour
permettre au jeune papa de s'investir
davantage dans la parentalité et la vie
du foyer une bonne nouvelle version pour
les intéressés un reportage à firminy et
saint-chamond dans la loire avec anthony
vers pillon de la chaîne locale tl7 télé
loire 7
jérémy est papa d'un petit malone et
dimanche et ils profitent de ces
premiers jours de congé paternité à la
maternité de firminy et même si mal aux
aînés le 27 juin
le terme de la grossesse était programmé
pour le 10 juillet jérémy va donc rester
28 jours en congé paternité
une très bonne nouvelle pour lui et sa
compagne bonne surprise très bonne
surprise
ouais ouais comme ça on va pouvoir
profiter bien comme il faut tous les
trois et c'est un premier donc voilà on
a besoin d'être avec lui on a besoin
d'apprendre à le connaître aussi la
besoin d'apprendre à nous connaître et
le jeune papa a déjà pu profiter des
premiers jours de son bébé grâce au lit
mis en place dans la chambre
résultat du label maternité ami des
bébés obtenu par le siège du corbusier
la place du papa et elle est très
importante pour accueillir un petit bébé
prendre sa place auprès de auprès de ce
bébé pente
prendre une place importante pour
soutenir la maman
voilà il faut du temps pour ça la
présence un constat partagé ici à la
maternité de saint chamond et si les
professionnels de la petite enfance sont
nombreux à préférer un congé plus long
ce d'élèves de 28 jours s'intercale
parfaitement dans les 1000 premiers
jours de l'enfant essentiel à son
développement
les 1000 jours il commença à la con sen
dès le premier jour de la conception du
bébé jusqu'à peu près les jusqu'à ces
deux ans vraiment la période le socle de
la vie futur et ce qui conditionne la
vie
adultes de cette personne les seuls chez
qui ce rallongement ne fait pas
l'unanimité finalement ce sont les chefs
d'entreprise pour eux ce nouveau congé
paternité va complexifier l'organisation
des entreprises
ça peut sembler ici paix mais vous savez
dans l'est dans l'est dans les grosses
entreprises je pense ça posera pas de
problème mais dans les petites
entreprises
chaque compétence est unique et lorsqu
ils vous mentent ou une compétence pour
un mois ces remplacements là quand on a
des compétences qui sont uniques
elles sont difficiles à dupliquer et
sachez qu'un peu moins de neuf mille
naissances sont enregistrées chaque
année dans la loire dans le reste de
l'actualité les dégâts matériels en
martinique
lille a été touchée il ya quelques jours
par l'ouragan elsa le premier la saison
cyclonique
les vents violents notamment endommagé
voiture et habitations et une belle
frayeur pour les habitants de l'île mais
fort heureusement aucun dégât humain
n'est à déplorer c'est au vauclin que
l'une des plus fortes rafales a été
enregistré selon météo france elles
atteignaient 146 kilomètres/heure les
détails en images avec sandrine claude
et yann boulard de la rédaction de via à
tv martinique sur place gaborik a permis
les cas y caser tous ces produits on
appelle 20 secondes de violentes rafales
ont eu raison de la toiture de cette
habitation inoccupée au moment des faits
elle a littéralement été éventré par
l'ouragan el zhar l'étole ont fini leur
course contre la propriété de ce
riverain d'un seul go rien n'a pas le
gêner il vivait toiture live à imiter
film au niveau qu'on est basé ménages
algo mois us la tonne emporté une partie
de leurs gardes de corps les occupants
des lieux sont encore très choquée par
la violence des événements
c'est avec soulagement que cette jeune
adolescente retrouve sa mère absente
lors des faits elle a craint le pire en
artois jay un bruit est un site
allez voir on a vu que tout ça ne fait
pas tomber
j'ai eu peur parce que la maison a
tremblé et puis
mais ma soeur a commencé à crier on est
quand même inquiet après c'est vrai
qu'on habite au bord du littoral donc ça
c'est c'est à prévoir cela dit moi
j'étais au travail donc c'est ma fille
qui m'a prévenu
donc j'étais enfant j'étais beaucoup
angoissé et voilà c'est parce que c'est
difficile c'est au vauclin que l'une des
plus fortes rafales a été enregistrée
lors du passage de l'ouragan
selon météo france elles atteignaient
146 kilomètres tout à fait autre chose
dans l'actualité à limoges la lutte
contre la discrimination homophobe se
dessine sur les passages piétons un
collectif local regroupant plusieurs
associations a réussi à fédérer l'état
et les collectivités pour aboutir à la
création de passages piétons
encadrés par le drapeau l'arc en ciel
symbole de paix de respect vous le savez
à cette occasion un rassemblement était
organisé notamment devant la préfecture
et la bibliothèque de limoges
propos recueillis par alain dru au de la
rédaction de 7 à limoges sur place
c'est une lutte de tous les jours
effectivement certains jeunes
aujourd'hui sont rouges qui veut le
message alors envoyé c'est
tenez bon soyez vous même soyez
vous-même surtout et continuer d'avancer
personnellement je pense que c'est
important parce que ça montre aux
personnes que ce sens est plus commun
que ce que certains peuvent penser et du
coup je pense que c'est important de
défendre des droits quand on n'est pas
encore tous égaux que nous le faisons
pour nous rappeler à chacun que nous
devons penser à la vie ordinaire des
autres et à ne pas nous mêler de ce qui
ne nous concerne pas
à tout autre sujet à présent avec le
début de la saison des pommes de terre
chaque français en consomment en moyenne
50 kg par an et cette année a été bien
sûr chamboulé à cause de l'épidémie du
coronavirus alors comment la production
de pommes de terre c'était l'adapter
producteurs et intermédiaires outils
beaucoup souffert du contexte
éléments de réponse dans l'avion de
marmande avec baptiste monge et de télé7
la chaîne le groupe sud ouest pour ce
conditionneurs de pommes de terre c'est
la première livraison de la journée à
dans une même comme ça on reçoit à peu
près dix tonnes de pommes de terre
ces patates ont été arrachées de la
terre par les producteurs autour de 6
heures du matin puis sont la vie est
emballé ici avant d'être envoyé à des
supermarchés des points de vente dans la
france entière
ça c'est le profil parfait et on est
dans des terres sableuses et confronte
un petit peu on voit que la pomme de
terre derrière et très blanche elle a
aucun défaut et là pas de choquer la
paille et les pas verte voilà on est
vraiment sûr sur la pomme de terre
nouvelle
durant l'été cette entreprise va
conditionner 12000 tonnes de pommes de
terre récoltées dans la région de
marmande c'est la haute saison ce qui
fait toute l'originalité des métiers de
la pomme de terre nouvelle récolte c'est
qu'on est en foot en russie
avait dix-huit jeunes qui arrivent et
bah vous devez vendre les pistes du mal
parce qu'elle ne concerne pas cette
pomme de terre on voit la vente très
près la crise sanitaire a provoqué les
problèmes de stockage chez les
producteurs beaucoup n'ayant pas pu
écouler leur production ici l'activité
est lancé on a quand même en scène
ticket en avait une petite baisse
mais là encore une fois c'est difficile
de son pas de jeter on commence juste
les connaissent pas les commandes sans
me rendez vous chaque année 5 à 6
millions de tonnes de pommes de terre
sont produites en france
nous vous parlions de baccalauréat en
début de ce journal est bien la
formation et l'éducation sont aussi
l'objet de la chronique écorégions de
michel picaud bonjour michel vous nous
parler aujourd'hui d'une plate forme qui
a su capter le désir d'apprentissage des
français il s'agit de super prof une
plateforme d'enseignement qui a super
paire formée du fait des périodes de
confinement bonjour série le bonjour à
tous les français ont envie d'apprendre
et ce phénomène s'est accéléré durant
les différentes périodes de confinement
que nous avons connue ces derniers mois
apprendre une langue apprendre
l'histoire et même apprendre à jouer de
la guitare
tout peut s'apprendre alors ne pouvons
pas ou peu sortir de chez soi
les français ont choisi et cours en
ligne et c'est ce que nous démontre la
plateforme française super prof qui en
2020 a vu les demandes de formation sur
son site x 5 voire par dix le mouvement
était renforcé par la crise sanitaire
mais il avait commencé avant et surtout
il continue encore aujourd'hui trois
chiffres en 2016 l'entreprise a réalisé
un million d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
13 millions d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires en 2020 et 20 millions sont
prévus cette année
ils sont aujourd'hui 200 à travailler
pour super prof
cette plate forme je vous le rappelle a
été créé en 2013 à biarritz le site met
en relation des élèves vous et moi qui
cherchant une formation avec des
professeurs agréés contrôler et qui se
sont inscrits sur le site
ils sont dans le monde 15 millions 15
millions de professeurs vous en
trouverez donc un facilement près de
chez vous ensuite le court et en
présentiel ou en distance yale et c'est
vous qui payez directement le professeur
le business model est en basé sur les
adhésions au site le modèle de formation
à distance médine biarritz devenu
parisien s'exporte aujourd'hui dans 34
pays et débarquera prochainement en
russie et en chine
merci michel picaud rendez vous dans une
prochaine édition
zoom à présent sur une méthode pour le
moins étonnante pour lutter contre la
prolifération de la chenille
processionnaire c'est son nom est à
toulouse des services de la ville
utilise depuis peu un pistolet paintball
pour lutter contre celle-ci
celui ci permet d'envoyer dans les
arbres des billes d'amidon contenant des
phéromones
une méthode qui doit permettre
d'empêcher la reproduction de cette
chenille nuisible à la fin pour les
arbres et dangereuses pour les animaux
et les hommes
explications au micro de la dépêche du
midi nos partenaires sur place
donc là je vais envoyer avec un pistolet
à air comprimé dire paintball débit un
chargé de phéromones sexuelles
donc ces petites billes jaunes la
pellicule à dur et de l'amidon donc
totalement naturel et les pulpes donc de
ses billes a même si elle tombe au sol
vont être détruits naturellement par
l'humidité et la pluie nous savons tous
le recyclage participe à la préservation
de l'environnement
alors comment nous encourager à trier
davantage et bien une initiative
innovante et connectés nous incite à
trier davantage le vert en ou
récompensant plusieurs collectivités ont
équipé leurs bornes de collecte de ce
nouveau dispositif
alors comment marche-t-il les habitants
se laisse-t-il tenter par ces
récompenses
réponse avec christophe rigaud dans
l'agglomération de lens liévin regarder
lorsque caroline dépose ses bouteilles
de verre dans sept bornes de tri
elle ne quitte jamais son smartphone et
pour cause
grâce à cette application chaque
bouteille ou pots en verre déposé lui
rapporte des points pour les enfants par
exemple s'est lui dit de m tiens un
point pouces si on fait pas bien les
choses on a le poussin verser les points
récoltés par caroline sont ensuite
convertis en avantage et bons d'achat ça
donne accès à des points
des remises dans certains magasins ça
peut intéresser les personnes et en plus
ça fait travailler les commerces de
proximité
dominique lui utilise le dispositif
kling depuis deux ans un petit geste
écologique et une récompense très
apprécié je recycle et mes gonds avait
en plus quoi et comment maintenant on a
les avantages ça me donne plus envie de
recycler quoi quelques pourcentages
quelques remises intéressantes pointe
une centaine de commerçants de
l'agglomération de lens sont partenaires
du dispositif
comme ce pâtissier haut de gamme du
centre ville ici ils ont par exemple le
choix on leur offre avec le déjeuner du
midi un apéritif ou une remise de 10% la
semaine dernière moi j'ai demandé à mon
épouse on a une dizaine de personnes qui
sont présentes et quand même et qui ont
bénéficié de la ronis citer les
habitants à mieux trier leurs déchets
c'était l'objectif de la cale la
communauté d'agglomération de lens
liévin et pour cet élu depuis
l'installation des bornes connecter les
comportements ont changé on retrouve et
de bouteilles à droite à gauche dans la
commune ne parle pas aux cons qui est
derrière nous
c'est l'exemple patent que je me
promenais je trouvais x bouteille et
c'est vrai qu'après qu'on a mis en place
ce processus j'ai vu une certaine
discipline qui s'est instaurée donc leur
mission de la calmer lancé deux équipes
et un maximum de bornes d'apport
volontaire de ce processus pour dire que
l'ensemble des 250 mille et quelques
habitants de la cale et puissent en
bénéficier
et depuis ou 2018 573 tonnes de verre
supplémentaires ont été collectés
l'agglomération va élargir le dispositif
à l'ensemble des 36 communes
début 2000 22 50% des conteneurs seront
équipées du dispositif klink tout à fait
autre chose l'été le soleil la chaleur
et le repos qui les accompagnent vous
profiterez sûrement de cette saison pour
lire des nouveautés ou feuilleter des
classiques rangé dans votre bibliothèque
et parmi les romans à succès du moment
il y à arras de yann moix
nous sommes en duplex avec lui bonjour
yann moix
on vous avait laissé il ya un an et demi
avec orléans
ouvrage dans lequel vous racontiez votre
enfance maltraitée vous revenez en
librairie avec reims un livre qui
s'inscrit dans une tétralogie intitulé
au pays de l'enfance immobile dans reims
on vous retrouve à l'âge de 20 ans dans
une école de commerce ou porter un
regard très sombre mais aussi caustique
sur ce qu'on présente comme le plus bel
âge alors cela veut dire que vous
n'étiez pas heureux à 20 ans yann moix
définitivement oui civile
excellente question l'âge de 20 ans pour
moi et n'est pas l'âge le pire ni plus
heureux c'est l'âge où on peut essayer
tout et son contraire
c'est l'âge des possibles c'est l'âge
des excès c'est l'âge des vicissitudes
c'est l'âge où on décide finalement non
pas de la vie qu'on aura mais on décide
du présent qu'on essaie d'avoir on
trouve sa place on cherche c'est un
cahier de brouillon et je pense que
c'est l'âge où il faut faire n'importe
quoi
à 10 ans c'est trop tôt à 30 ans c'est
trop tard vingt ans ces moments de la
vie où il faut se lâcher c'est ce que
j'ai fait dans tous les domaines pour le
meilleur et pour le pire
dans votre livre vous racontez aussi la
découverte de la littérature que vous
placer au dessus de tout c'est à cette
époque que vous avez eu le déclic pour
devenir écrivain yann moix le déclic
pour la littérature avait lieu avant
mais comme à sup de co reims les femmes
ne voulaient pas de moi
moi je ne voulais pas des études la
ville était horrible reims était
vraiment un cimetière pour les vivants à
l'époque qui ça a changé il n'y avait
pas internet et que le portable
n'existaient pas il restait deux choses
pour les étudiants les cours de
comptabilité pour ceux qui voulaient y
aller la masturbation à la littérature
j'ai gardé les deux derniers et j'ai
fait les deux quasiment à égalité
heureusement la littérature l'a emporté
sur le côté masturbatoire ya moi que
vous avez reçu plusieurs prix
littéraires prestigieux vous avez
construit une oeuvre littéraire reconnu
et en même temps on vous retrouve sur
des plateaux de télé très populaire
comment expliquez vous cette dualité qui
peut apparaître comme paradoxal voire
contradictoire avec votre carrière
d'écrivain est ce que ça ne va pas la
desservir finalement déjà on a le droit
de s'amuser
on n'est pas obligé d'être enfermé dans
sa chambre toute la journée pour écrire
et puis ça fait partie du 21e siècle que
de faire des choses sur internet de la
télévision du cinéma etc
moi j'ai trouvé ma place c'est la
littérature ses livres donc on peut
aussi une fois qu'on a trouvé sa place
graviter autour et revenir au bercail
ensuite c'est comme une cour de
récréation
j'ai beaucoup de plaisir à faire de la
télévision
intellectuellement et aussi j'allais
dire physiquement parce que j'adore le
direct et quand on est en direct qui se
passe vraiment quelque chose et j'ai dit
oui à cyril hanouna parce que à mon avis
et je pèse mes mots c'est l'équivalent
de michel polac au xxème siècle c'est à
dire que c'est aujourd'hui là que ça se
passe que c'est un bazar pas possible
qu'on est en direct et qu'il ya parfois
des choses assez profond qui sont
abordés malgré les apparences persillade
moi que d'avoir répondu avec question as
c'est votre nouvel ouvrage aux éditions
grasset est disponible en librairie et
sur internet
bon été à vous tout à fait autre chose
on part pour monaco le chef mauro
colagreco proposé il ya quelques jours à
live cooking dans le restaurant nouvelle
génération comme monaco
comprenez une séance de cuisine en
direct orchestré par le chef triplement
étoilé à un moment privilégié pour les
quelques clients qui ont pu y assister
et goûter à sa cuisine de haute qualité
de quoi vous donner l'eau à la bouche
avec ce reportage de charlotte moreno
pour monaco info regarder les tomates il
faut bien un par un des plats ou en
couleurs et en saveurs élaboré au regard
de tous voici quelques idées du menu
d'hier soir un homard bleu accompagné de
pêche blanche et gèle d'osmanthus décoré
d'un carpaccio de tomates 1 saint pierre
avec des courgettes trompette girolles
et une marinière crémer à la verveine
mauro colagreco propose toujours une
cuisine parfumée de fraîcheur avec des
fusions délicate et se réjouit de la
partager avec la clientèle monégasque
chaque fois que je viens c'est un vrai
plaisir on a des habitués qui viennent
justement pour ces dates spéciales et
c'est que du bonheur donc c'est bien de
pouvoir partager avec eux être près
d'eux depuis l'activité irrégulière
qu'impose la crise sanitaire le monde de
la restauration doit aller chercher les
clients
c'est en organisant ce genre
d'événements qu'on attire une clientèle
complémentaire et aujourd'hui on en a
besoin pour maintenir une activité
des clients privilégiés à la fois
spectateur et dégustateurs qui ont pu
échanger directement avec le chef
le moment le plus important c'est quand
même de rencontrer le cuisinier dont
tout le monde parle des côté restaurant
une équipe formée par mauro colagreco
exécute tous les jours ses recettes
prochainement deux nouveaux chefs
s'inviteront chico monaco chaque semaine
pour faire deux plats enlève cooking on
reste à table dans ce grand jt des
territoires avec la 13e édition du
concours d'huile d'olive organisée en
corse par le syndicat chargé de
l'appellation d'origine contrôlée
là au p 16 huile d'olive étaient en
compétition cette année dans deux
catégories distinctes récolte sur
l'arbre et récolte à l'ancienne alors
quelles sont les différences entre ces
deux techniques
explications de via télé pas aisée la
chaîne locale de la tnt sur place en
réponse il avoue récolté via des moyens
eux peigne vibreur les hauts lieux qui
sont sur la donc ça c'est pour la récole
sur la récolte à l'ancienne c'est par
chute naturelle dont vous mettez des
filets et c'est les olives qui tombent
naturellement avec le vent ou parce
qu'elles arrivent à un stade de maturité
importants paraît qu'on vous évaluez sur
des critères différents selon les
typicités moyenne récoltes et des
sourires et de la bonne humeur
maintenant pour terminer cette édition à
metz les frigos lieux alternatifs et
culturel et solidaire ont ouvert pour le
plus grand bonheur des habitants
réhabiliter les anciens entrepôts
frigorifiques militaire proposons tout
l'été des animations sous le signe de la
bonne humeur
c'est the place to be et ont certes un
reportage d'anne sophie grosse pour vyas
moselle tv sur place
la guinguette la plus prisée de metz a
rouvert ses portes dans ce décor
atypique aux allures de camp de vacances
les jeunes et les moins jeunes se sont
retrouvés autour d'un ou plusieurs
verres plus une table n'était libre dès
le début de soirée preuve que la
réouverture des frigos été très très
attendus par les médecins fassent plutôt
pas mal
ouais ouais je suis hyper contente parce
que ça fait deux ans qu'on attend ça
avec impatience donc on est super
contentes c'est vraiment banlieue où on
peut se détendre
pour tous les âges et cetera il ya des
palaces et nouveau il ya des animations
avant il y avait pas l'année dernière
mais je trouve que c'est super c'est
super sympa nous on a l'habitude de
venir les années précédentes et c'est
vrai que c'est très chaleureux
en clair l'inauguration n'aurait pas pu
mieux se passer souvent dépassé la messe
est noire de monde on est super content
mais c'est quand même un lieu atypique à
metz déjà le bâtiment est magnifique on
a une esplanade vraiment à disposition
du public
du coup les gens espaces sont dehors il
ya cet effet pas cette ambiance des
regards directeur et attendent donc
voilà on est très contents les gens
dansent au sein de ses frigos tous les
ingrédients sont réunis pour faire
recette des fous de traque des bars dont
les files d'attentes ne désemplissent
pas et surtout l'ingrédient magique qui
rend ce lieu si attractif une ambiance
festive et conviviale les gens dansent
les gens rient bonne humeur garantie
c'est super convivial ya il ya plein de
monde de toutes sortes de
de tous styles et puis j'ai beaucoup
aimé le groupe qui a joué juste avant
qu'ils ont mis grave de l'ambiance était
super sympa on sait faire avec le
festival au peuple je crois que on est
on est assez doué en ambiance donc voilà
venez venez vous attabler venez manger
vous venez boire vous venez passer un
bon moment venez écouter des artistes et
vous passerez un bon moment est d'autant
que chaque jour une programmation
différente et proposer des spectacles
pour enfants aux biens yoga en passant
par des initiations de danse
autant dire que les festivités sont loin
d'être terminées et même s'ils ne sont
plus ardents l'ambiance de ses frigos
promet d'être chaude tout l'été pour la
merci de nous avoir suivi sur vos
chaînes locales de la tnt et sur tv5
monde
rendez vous très vite pour une prochaine
édition au revoir à tous et bon courage
[Musique]